So it starts in 1989 and it's July and I'm on tour with my band and we're
touring through Europe and this is a very usual thing I had been touring for
years and years seven or eight years by that point so it we had just come from
Israel and we had landed in the UK in England so I had never been to Israel
before and the first time you go there all the security is a bit daunting you
know they search you and they search you again and they ask you questions and I
found it a little scary so even though I really enjoyed my time there I was
looking forward to coming back to England which was very familiar to me so
this was we just landed in England we were staying at the Holiday Inn Airport
near Heathrow very glamorous so I wake up that morning and that night I'm going
to play at the Glastonbury Festival in Glastonbury so we have a journey to go
to and it's probably going to be the biggest audience I'm ever going to face
where there's supposed to be 75,000 or 80,000 people there and I'm headlining
that night it's a Friday night so I'm the last act on the show and all this is
okay this is fine I pack my stuff I go downstairs to the to the front desk and
there's some kind of altercation at the desk and I see my bass player Mikey and
he's looking really unhappy he's looking really pale and he's like I have Puerto
Rico and half Italian so pale is not his usual color so I am concerned about this
and then I also see my tour manager also looking really upset my manager there's
all this kind of buzzing going on I'm like what's going on so we all knew that
there had been some girl that had a crush on Mike you know and this happens
from time to time you know girls fall in love with the guys in the band and I
try and stay out of it you know and they send things or whatever and I try and lay
down rules you know we don't want random girls on the bus but you can have your
girlfriend or you can have your wife random girls off the bus but I kind of
knew about this random girl because she it started off with little gifts that
were coming backstage from Mike email thought that was really cute and then
after that graduated to pictures of herself naked and well whatever so but
then we all became worried because she had actually moved to Queens from London
to be near him when we were not on tour and we all felt that that was going too
far so now it turned out that now we're back in the UK and we are going to play
Glastonbury and she has called him in the middle of the night and made these
threats and said to him that she she and her friend who is a male guy who was
also calling the hotel we're going to shoot him if he went out on stage that
night so I'm like oh god I hate I hate that kind of day because I just want to
be in England where it's just nice you know and it was comfortable and it was
you know and Glastonbury is a festival of hippies basically they have a big
peace sign on the stage so and I'm thinking is this really gonna happen but
my manager feels that we should take it seriously so we call Scotland Yard so
we're all waiting for Mr. Scotland Yard to show up the detective shows up and he
takes the trip with us on the bus Mike is freaking out everybody's freaking out
so and I'm like okay so he asks us some questions he finds out some things about
this girl he finds out some things about the other man who was making the calls
and this kind of thing so the tension is kind of building it's a long trip and we
finally get there and we wind our way through this crowd of people and we're
trying to find our way backstage to where the bus is supposed to be and it's
kind of muddy I think it had rained and then it had stopped raining so now
there's all this dust and stuff in the air and as throngs of people and we're
trying to find our way backstage and once we get there I feel that I I need
to go for a walk I need a little privacy and I try and go for a walk I figure
I'll check out some of the booths that are selling tie-dyed things and military
surplus Mr. Scotland Yard wants to walk with me and I'm like no no it's okay
you know you stay with Mike I'll be fine no miss Vega I feel I really should come
with you no I don't want you to come with me you can stay with Mike I need to
go off and he said no so I said okay fine I'll stay here then we were gonna
go on stage at about 11 o'clock at about 930 suddenly four or five policemen show
up and they come onto the bus and they want to have a little chat with me and
I'm like why you know Mike will be fine he's gonna perform on the side of the
stage we have two bodyguards for Mike he's gonna perform in a bulletproof vest
he's got the two bodyguards are there one looks like mr. clean and one looks
like GI Joe and they're very handsome guys and they're gonna defend Mike's I'm
like great what's the problem so the policemen sit me down and they said well
we didn't want to tell you this because we were we didn't want to upset you but
your life was also threatened they also said miss Vega if you go out on stage
you will also get it so being that we have tracked down the woman but we
haven't tracked down her accomplice we feel that we need to inform you legally
that you should not do this show tonight we feel that you should not perform on
stage tonight so I'm like what are you kidding like this is Friday night I'm
headlining the Glastonbury festival there's like a hundred thousand people
what do you mean I'm not gonna do the show of course I'm gonna do the show you
know the show must go on what are you talking about no one's gonna like shoot
me on the Glastonbury stage under the peace sign so and then I'm thinking well
anyway you don't want to know what I was thinking so so I said no no I'm said I
really have to do the show I feel that I really must and my my keyboard player
who's also my boyfriend is looking at me with tears in his eyes and he's like no
no I don't think you should do it I'm like I'm sorry we have to do it how can
we possibly come back to England if we don't do this show you know any crazy
person can call up on the phone and say you know whatever they're gonna say and
then we they everybody would know that we cancelled so they said okay well
you'll have to wear the bulletproof vest as well so I said okay the only one they
had was his and this policeman was about 250 pounds and I'm like half that size
so they put it on me and it's enormous and he strapped me in and they gaffers
tape it closed so I'm like okay and I'm like can I still play the guitar I think
so and then I have a they put a huge denim jacket on over that so no one
sees the bulletproof vest so now I'm all decked out like a turtle like this and
my arms are kind of like this I'm like okay but you know I felt really strongly
that we should we should go on we should risk our lives you know this is rock and
roll this is what this is what we do so I remember that moment as I was walking
out on the stage and I see the microphone there and I'm in my denim
jacket and my gaffers tape and my bulletproof vest and things start to
feel like I'm going underwater and as I'm heading for the microphone the
thought suddenly occurs to me that they could shoot me in the head and I'm like
oh I wish I hadn't thought that right now but I not thinking about that anymore
I'm just heading for the microphone and then I pick up the guitar and I start
singing and the other thing that happened was that now this whole
situation has escalated to the point where there's 20 policemen in front of
the stage there's a hundred thousand people behind them there's people as far
as the eye can see from the stage all the way to the horizon this is like
several villages or something not only that but there's helicopters overhead
and they've decided to train the lights not on the stage which they usually do
but from time to time they swivel the lights onto the audience to search them
to see if they see anyone with a weapon so I'm singing every song feels like
it's taking 20 minutes long small blue thing just seems to go on forever and
I'm looking at every so often they swivel the lights onto the audience and
I'm like you know and I continue to play and every so often I turn around to look
at Mike of course he's not there you know Mike is over there with mr. clean
the GI Joe and there's the his amplifier on the floor so it's like
where's Mike oh there's his amp so blah blah I'm playing it's all going pretty
well I'm thinking wow this is great that we're alive and suddenly my keyboard
player approaches me and he says sing Luca and get off stage and I'm like why
and he goes I can't tell you right now but we have to get off stage by 1230
and I'm like okay and then I start thinking well why do they want me to get
off stage did they find some did they find the weapon did they find the girl
did they find her accomplice maybe I should just get off stage and not sing
Luca Luca was my big hit at that point and it was and I decided no we're gonna
stay we're gonna sing Luca we're gonna entertain everybody I've come to be
entertained we have to do this I sing Luca everybody's cheering I come off
stage it feels like it's going in slow motion and I said what happened did they
find the girl no did they find her accomplice no they find somebody with a
weapon no well why did we have to get off stage at 1230 and then the promoter
of the festival comes over to me and says with Miss Vega we didn't get a
chance to explain this to you before but the festival has a curfew because the
farmers in the next field have the cows and the cows get disturbed if you sing
past 1230 and it makes them less productive and that's my story